[Musique]
non
nous sommes sur le tapis rouge de ce 64e
festival de cannes pour un film au
casting totalement improbable puisque
dans still water il y à matt damon
camille caudin et dimitri payet le film
se passe à marseille et une scène au
vélodrome 12 10 litres et payet on a
parlé à toute l'équipe du film ainsi
qu'à tous les invités de ce 64e festival
de cannes
regardez tous un peu too much ou seydou
béton soit je dis comment ça va
très bien
qu'est ce que la présence le festival
pour vous ce sont les débuts c'est la
toute première fois pour moi je suis
tellement heureuse je suis vraiment
joyeux
j'attends leurs films que je représente
ici et même si c'est de la science
fiction même si ça se déroule à l'avenir
c'est un bon film je suis honoré d'y
participer
[Musique]
comment ça va écoutez ça va super bien
surtout parce que j'ai vu le
premier film depuis 16 mois dans salle
de projection donc vous pouvez imaginer
le bonheur à la conférence de presse du
jury kléber méleau il a dit que le
cinéma brésilien est entré en état de
résistance ou partager oui je pense
qu'on est en état de résistance depuis
l'élection de bolton arrow qui
malheureusement a plongé le pays dans
une crise de la pandémie mais aussi une
crise économique sociale et culturelle
vraiment sans égale donc on est dans la
résistance notre cinémathèque
brésilienne est fermé depuis un an et
quelques maintenant les productions sont
suspendus c'est très très dur mais on va
retourner cela
week-end
ouais
très bien et vous ben oui j'ai tellement
de mon fait
si water ici la sensation de myspace à
tous les ans donc pour lui c'est là
c'est comme aller acheter le pain valu à
servier lui sert de paratonnerre c'est
vrai non non c'est merveilleux de son
mauvais ça fait quatre ans qu'on en
parle a commencé à travailler sur ce
film avec tom est formidable c'est un
film français américains politique
une histoire d'amour il ya tellement de
choses dans tant de fil que vraiment
réalisez votre premier film français en
vue de la réalisation
le fait de réaliser ce film c
les élites de matt guerrier d'être un
marché de travail avec thomas et les
autres scénaristes y avait des équipes
paris de mise
j'avais une équipe des états unis aussi
c'était comme un mariage de style de jeu
différent dre les un film à marseille
dans cette union parce qu'il s'agit
toujours de réaliser un film
je pense que matt vient d'arriver à
entendre les cris et il est là il le
fait à chaque fois
comment ça va rester ensemble qu'il a la
même chose et leurs pires a travaillé
avec top et crise sans arrêt et les
méchants à tout le monde en fait non on
n'y a rien de méchant tu attires tout
est formidable c'est c'est chouette je
vais poser la même question
la question que j'ai posée at home
c'était comment réaliser votre premier
film français vous êtes est chouette de
la ville de marseille marseille joue un
rôle dans le film et les acteurs qu'elle
a rencontré les équipes et tous c'est
issam cette influence et vu l'état des
deux cinémas aux états unis on est
content de venir en france voilà qu'elle
comptait travailler avec ces deux là un
honneur un plaisir j'ai tellement appris
la vérité en français ils sont durs très
durs
comment ça s'est passé comment comment
comptez vous êtes retrouvés tous
ensemble
à marseille on a vécu un sens à
marseille pendant deux mois
et
voilà c'était très c'était convivial
c'était studieux c'est joyeux
parce que tom va venir s'installer en
france
oui elle vous a donné des conseils
vis-à-vis de comment vous comporter
comme en français je suis nul en
français tu le sais bien dédié mais le
fait d'être avec camille je n'avais qu'à
les impôts gratter et j'étais
instantanément temps le la scène je suis
très fort c'est cette chimie en jolie
créé à
or à cause de vous et personne ce qui
venait de d'endroits différents qui se
retrouvent et je suis vraiment ravi avec
les résultats et c'est grâce à elle
c'est une histoire très belle a beaucoup
de ce niveau comment est ce que vous
décrivez cette histoire en fait c'est
l'avalanche d'émotion ma partie préférée
et le fait qu'il n'y a pas de bruit de
méchant tout le monde est un peu perdu
chacun essaie de chercher et de trouver
son chemin et c'est un film qui se
parlent
il explique comment on peut beaucoup
peindre avec la traduction une petite
erreur peut être des impacts sur la vie
de beaucoup de personnes et le lien
familial et très fort le lien entre un
père et sa fille